long ago the world was full of wonder it  was adventurous there was magic  but it wasn't easy to master so the  world found a simpler way to get by but  I hope there's a little magic left in  you your dad said to give you this when  you were both over 16 it's a wizard step  dad was a wizard your dad was an  accountant  this spell brings him back watch back  way back to life that's not possible it  is with this I'm gonna meet dad  [Music]  dad 24 hours to bring the rest of him  back we're going on  [Music]  I think we should take the path apparel  but keeps persuade these bastards know  the long run fine dad gotta go  there could be booby traps  before you cast a spell again you're  gonna have to practice  elbows out feet apart back looks like  [Music]  well we need spell that creates a  magical bridge you can walk on if you  believe the bridge is there then it's  there you can do this  you  you